[Music]
you do you but don't say you're gonna be
great unless you realize you have to
become obsessed like you can't be the
best at something in the world
Bassem yeah what up bro you're here with
Aubrey Marcus and I what's your name
where you from I'm a virgin it's awesome
in thanks for calling what can we answer
for you chef I'm in culinary school
right now I'm trying to make a fine
house a little sharpening knives where
do you think the best how do you think
the best way to approach this is well
what do you mean like you want to get
paid for for sharpening knives yeah way
to continually make money on the side I
love this idea I'm gonna give you a
tremendous piece of advice that to many
people that are ideological and don't
actually play in the game push against
but I believe in it the most
[Music]
you should go sharpen knives for five
restaurants for free for free okay yep
like what like I spoke for free for the
first 13 for no actually I paid for the
first one good that's how it also for
mmm 13 of the first 15 times I ever
spoke I spoke for free including paying
for my flights it's one thing to do free
work it's another thing to do free work
with heavy strategy
when I do free work I try to think of
two things how much exposure is it like
Tyler will tell you sitting right here
one of the only times I still do free
work is if it's massive exposure there
are 49,000 people in the audience among
you you know like like it's live on you
know it's throwing the soup I like like
I'll pay somebody to put me in a
Superbowl commercial right like when
they when I get exposure or and that's
where I'm at now in the for you when you
pick these five restaurants let it be
the biggest restaurants in your 30 mile
radius
let it be the kindest let it be somebody
who has the biggest Instagram following
and maybe like whether you know you
never want to give with expectation but
it's it's okay to ask you're like hey
I'd love to sharpen your knives for free
and then like you get in there and the
vibes are feeling good maybe like hey
listen like I hope you enjoyed it like
wouldn't mind to take a picture for my
Instagram which then makes them say oh
we'll put you on our Instagram like you
can be thoughtful and do it the right
way but if nothing else if you do it for
free for five people you've established
that you do it
word of mouth there's a remarkably
fascinating thing and sharpen the [ __ ]
out of those knives - oh yeah kill it
like kill it
make sure you the best [ __ ] knife
sharpener there is great point by Aubrey
the amount of people have gotten into my
inner circle have sat right out there
they're now on the cusp but then aren't
here nine months later because they
weren't good at their craft or they
didn't squeeze the [ __ ] out of their
opportunity that happens too and I think
sharpening the [ __ ] out of those knives
really matters look bro hard [ __ ]
works appreciated everywhere hard work
is a cost of act like there's nobody
that's ever been successful that made it
that didn't put in hard work there are
people that inherited money like there
are people that have money that didn't
work hard there's nobody who's made it
they made it the merit of them making it
that didn't put in ridiculous hard work
that person does not exist that person
does not exist
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah but for whom matters to like these
things [ __ ] matter you like you
sharpening the [ __ ] out of those knives
first for a restaurant owner who was
just thrilled to get some knives you
know sharpen for free feels no guilt or
has no interest in co-signing you and it
dies in that kitchen that night and
nothing happens also [ __ ] sucks but I
will say this somebody's always watching
so let's play this out you go and
sharpen that this is why I fully believe
in the senses you go to the number three
restaurant you sharpen the knives the
owners a [ __ ] got nothing for you
doesn't say to anybody doesn't put you
on Instagram doesn't even thank you
correctly and you're out but the
sous-chef was watching how hard you
worked and she in three years opens up
the number one [ __ ] spot and now she
and do you understand somebody's always
watching funny like you know like you
look at there's people out there whether
it's Kobe it's definitely what I push
there's people out there saying look you
do you but don't say you're gonna be
great unless you realize you have to
become obsessed like you can't be the
best at something in the world passively
yeah you have to Punk everything and
that's and that's and if you don't want
to be the best in the world or a top 100
that's amazing and like then you can
canoe in the afternoon and like go to a
coffee shop and just chill but if you
want it like to me it's just make your
actions map your words you don't need to
work on your craft 18 hours a day but
then also don't have the audacity to
ever say you're gonna be great or all
time I keep telling people Magic Johnson
two hours before he took the bus it as a
kid like that's what his sister's always
tell that story Larry Bird like taking a
billion shots and that crickety old like
that like yeah like again and I'm gonna
say it again
cuz because it's very real to me like
when I go Raj sale as a hobby on a
Saturday and wake up at 5:30 after in
[ __ ] working super hard this is
supposed to be like rest and this and
that like that that four hours of garage
selling and negotiating seeing what's
poppin and like I'm
feel my crap
[Music]